to Brandon Judd right now the national
border patrol council president Brandon
almost makes you feel like we have to do
what they're doing or plan to do in
Italy a blockade a little bit different
of course when you're talking about you
know a landlocked border here but I'm
just wondering uh what do you think of
the way Italy is dealing with this
well I think that what they're doing is
absolutely uh astonishing I think that
when you look at this liberal government
recognizing how bad this issue is the
people of Italy realizing how bad this
issue is and they're actually going to
start to do something yet our government
isn't going to follow suit you know
they're going to put up a blockade
because their laws allow them we can't
do a blockade even if we stretched our
border hand in hand with border patrol
agents that group of two 2200 migrants
across the border we can't push them
back into Mexico so we can't stop them
from coming we have to take them into
custody but there are other things that
this Administration could do to stop
this and we've proven that in the past
president Trump proved what policies are
are effective all we have to have from
this Administration is the proper policy
and we could stop this tomorrow they
just don't want to do it because they're
worried about their base supporters
they're worried that they're going to
get them out to the to the polls and so
they constantly appease them you know
but now those base supporters are
getting a little antsy if you think
about it right Baron because New York
mayor guidance of the New York
Democratic governor uncle are concerned
that this is so out of control of the
Border especially when it's at their
doorsteps when you've got a state that
it declared that it would be a sanctuary
State just a few years ago New Jersey
saying no Moss we can't deal with this
uh there is a division in the ranks
there
there's a little bit of a division but
that division hasn't grown big enough I
mean when you have AOC that goes out
that does a a rally in favor of people
coming to New York City saying that
there's a a good idea for a tax on the
American people to support these people
in New York city so there is a little
bit of a in the armor but it
hasn't grown big enough yet and Until
That Base changes its mind until that
base realizes that we have to do what's
best for this country not what's best
for other countries or for other people
from other countries until they realize
that we have to do what's best for this
country we're going to continue to see
this problem this Administration will
not do anything until its base changes
its mind yeah I'm wondering if that base
did get a little bit of a shocker though
Brandon when you know Alexander Casio
Cortez and Jerry Nadler two liberals who
were speaking to this group
um you were booed down essentially
shouted down I don't think they
anticipated that do you think that was a
wake-up moment or a short live one
I I think it's very short lived and what
they're doing and listening to all the
rhetoric on Capitol Hill I spent an
awful lot of time there listening to
that rhetoric what they're saying is
they're saying those were conservatives
that were out there saying that that
wasn't their base that's what that's the
rhetoric that's going around right now
and that's what they would have
everybody believe even though Neil you
and I both know that the citizens of New
York City they're fed up with this the
base is in fact fed up with it but until
there's a lot more voices out there this
Administration is going to continue
doing what they're doing remember we
could stop this tomorrow there are ways
to do it this Administration won't give
us that policy that's necessary real
quickly I think it hits home when it is
at home though when it is on the streets
in New York City just a couple of blocks
from here and you have hundreds of
migrants lined up I mean maybe that is
the moment
well New York for New York City it is
they've reached the breaking point the
border patrol we've reached the reached
the breaking point but that's New York
City that might be Los Angeles but
there's a bunch of other liberal cities
there's a bunch of liberal other liberal
states they haven't reached the breaking
point yet and so the base still is where
it's at they're not going to give up all
right you might be right about that
Brandon thank you very much hey everyone
I'm Emily compagno catch me and my
co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights